《红楼梦》被称为封建社会百科权署,这一点是得到众多读者工人的。从人情事故角度来关,红楼也是一本人情事态百科权署。曹雪芹真正做到了,人情练达及文章。这种练达就通过红楼人物关系展现出来。
就以贾宝为例。他对贾家子孙的宠爱程度是不同的。贾家子魅力、贾母对王熙凤、林黛玉、贾太春的宠爱就远远胜过营传和稀纯。
因为营稀两人口齿寻常,不太会成欢长辈,所以容易被贾母忽视。
我们读者在预读过程中,也能感受到这种人情信息。
罪天会来事儿的孩子,往往更容易得到长辈的喜欢。
把这种思维放在贾家男性子孙身上。
习惯红楼梦文本情节,贾母似乎只宠爱贾宝玉一个人。
就是读者最直观的感受。其实这个答案并不准确。
宝玉的德宠能被读者直观的看到是因为男主视角的原因。
其实家母还一场宠爱另一个孙子,便是假设的儿子王西奉的丈夫,佳脸。
红楼第44回,变身不测,奉劫破处。
佳脸和扑人之七,暴而家的丝魂,被半路回家换衣服的奉劫发觉。
佳脸脑袖承怒,借着酒劲儿拔出一把劲,就要杀奉劫。
奉劫逃到家母住处,佳脸也追到此处。
曹学金如是记录佳脸心里。
义语未完,直见佳脸拿着劲感来,后面许多人跟着。
佳脸名仗着佳母素席疼他们,连母亲身母也无爱,故承强弄了来。
媳妇认王妇认见了,记得盟男主骂斗,这下流种子,你越发反了,老太太在这里了。
佳脸一斜着眼,倒,都是老太太惯着她,她才这样,连母也骂起来了。
辞助明确提到,佳脸仗着佳母素席疼她,而读者读到这里多少会觉得有些空洞。
佳母疼爱宝玉处处可见,佳母疼爱佳脸则似乎无处可寻。
如果我们刻意把视角放在佳母佳脸,两个人的情节交给上,就会发现草血情的确擅长埋伏比。
佳母和佳脸的关系确实有宠爱的成分在,甚至我们可以推测,当年佳宝玉还未出生之前,佳母最宠爱的孙子很可能就是佳脸。
若文证据,布红军认为原住中至少有三处情节可供证明。
其一,原住第13回林如海病重,写信让待遇回佳一趟,佳母专门点名要佳脸亲自互送,可见对佳脸是何等信任。
尤其林如海病事后,需要处理一系列后续释疑,包括举办桑里潜散下人,林佳一场分配等等可能出现的问题。
佳母若不是十分信任佳脸,端然不会让她亲自互送。
当然,此一例只能证明佳母对佳脸的能力是信任的,并不能证明佳母宠爱佳脸,那么我们再来看第二处例子。
仍是第44回,凤姐拨祝风波过后,刺日佳脸久醒,心中着实后悔。
佳母叫来佳脸凤姐平耳,大家一起审问佳脸,而佳脸深通宠欢之道,三言两语就将佳母一行人斗得大笑。
原住记,佳脸听佳母说,便爬起来,与凤姐做了一个意,笑到,原来是我的不是,
二奶奶饶过我吧,满屋里的人都笑了,佳母笑到,奉压头不许脑了,再脑我就脑了。
说着,又命人去叫了平耳来,命凤姐和佳脸两个安慰平耳,佳脸见了平耳越发酷不得了,所谓欺不如切借不如偷,听佳母一说便赶上来说道,
姑娘昨日受了驱了,都是我的不是,奶奶得罪了你,也是英文而起,我陪了不是不算外,还替你奶奶陪个不是,说着也做了一个意,
赢得佳母笑了,凤姐也笑了。
诸君戏评这段文字,佳脸的情商简正没得说,再没有人能比她处理得更好了。
佳脸先是当着重人给凤姐做一,赢斗的佳母大笑,誓怀了老太太的心。
随后又连向平耳到了两次欠,一次是为自己,一次是为凤姐,因为昨天凤姐一时激脑悟打了平耳。
如此以来,原本应该生气的凤姐,见丈夫替自己道歉,反而不好意思为佳脸的出轨发伙了。
最终是,佳母笑了,凤姐也忍不住笑了,原本的审问,居然变得轻松于快起来。
佳脸这么做,有很大一部分原因是为了佳母,当着佳母的面得成欢负贺,不能惹老太太生气。
所以后文理,连凤夫妻俩一回到佳中,便又因为出轨的事,哭闹满愿了一阵。
如果说,佳脸互送灵带预有赞送期能力的因素,可以将其归之为智商,
那么佳脸能根据具体环境成欢长辈,则可归之为情商。
双伤皆被的佳脸,很难不被佳母喜欢。
还有第三处例子,便是佳母和佳脸的说话模式,佳母偶尔还会翻旧帐调侃佳脸。
具体可见原住第46回,冤枉女士绝冤枉偶。
佳是强取冤枉,佳母因此大怒,待着谁骂谁,好不容易平息下来怒气,
女院们据在一起打牌,佳脸过来打探消息,平而劝她不要去装腔口,
佳脸便在佳母门口偷偷先连着往里看。
佳后被佳母看在眼里,于是就有了这么一番对话。
佳母一回身,佳脸不防,便没躲零例,佳母便问,
外头是谁,倒向个小子一身头,佳脸忙进去陪佳道,
大听老太太十四个出门,好欲被叫着,佳母道,既这么样怎么不进来,又做鬼做神的。
佳脸陪佳道,见老太太玩牌不敢惊动,不过叫媳妇出来问问,
佳母道,就忙到这一时,等佳家去你问多少问不得,
那一招你这么小心来着,又不知是来做耳暴神的,
也不知是来做探子的,鬼鬼碎碎的,到虎尾一跳。
什么好下流种子,你媳妇和我玩牌呢,还有半日的空,
你家去再和那照耳家的商量治你媳妇去吧,
说着众人都笑了,原样笑道,暴耳家的,
老祖宗有拉伤照耳家的,佳母也笑道,
可是我哪里记得什么抱着背着的。
再次处佳母居然展现出高级幽默的天分,
明明奉劫铺土的事早已过去了,
而且所谓的两人商量害奉劫,
其实是王岐峰边出来,帮助自己战聚道德至高点的。
佳母却借力实力,条砍佳脸说,
你媳妇和我玩牌,还有半日的空,
你回去和照耳家的商量治你媳妇去吧。
而且把暴耳家的说成了照耳家的,
被冤枉糾正后,又使用邪影耿说,
我哪里记得什么抱着背着的,
无形中达成了一种绝妙的幽默效果。
这与薛盘把唐营念成耕黄,
被佳母与糾正后,薛盘都能说,
我哪知道什么唐营果营的。
二者真有意取同工之妙。
尤其是薛盘犯了这样的错,独者上能理解,
佳母如此身份,也犯相同的错误,
其幽默效果比薛盘有过之而无不及。
佳母之所以能激发出幽默感,
跟佳脸是她从小宠爱的孙子有直接关系,
因为宠爱所以轻力,开启玩笑来才能有任由于。
因此,我们有理由认为,
红龙梦的人情事故体系是相对完善的。
草血仅只要留下某种结论性信息,
苏州就一定有相应的福笔对照,
只是独者由于阅读事业的局限,
王王很难发现这些隐藏性信息。
这就要求独者要以更加细致的阅读方式来品味红楼。
民主长独长心的原因不外乎就是如此。
今天的红楼解读就到这里,
我们下一个视频再会。